[Music]
January 1
what's up guys just like that cut that
off drop that in note I'm dropping that
in note man cuz that cuz I'm dropping
that year I just dropped a year off
welcome to 2018 boy man I'm pumped
it's the future do you even know that it
is the future right now you know there
was a time when you were younger when
you were a child and you might have been
a you know a chubby child or you might
have you know I remember there was one
summer I had real fat thighs on me you
know cuz I come from people that's real
hearty in the ass you know I got that
ass and I got the ass and rear of kind
of a urban girl or a Down syndrome boy
or girl and you know I got that that fat
retention around my anus and hips and I
remember there was a there was a time
when I was young when a lot of when a
lot of I had some short shorts that had
to wear and I remember this how short
they were on me and just every time I
would go somewhere they would feel so
naughty you know I remember as a child
just feeling because they would bunch up
but it was just because my growth my
growth was headed down this wild little
wild little you know little route my
growth was going down this wild route
where I was gonna look a little you know
robust and and I remember my shorts
would just they would always creep up on
my thighs and be all naughty and I
remember you know at that time sometimes
men that were local men that were
probably you know kind of had those you
know that kind of had the devil just
just being stalking up and down their
spine you know just climbing up and down
their spine some men like that would
look at me I think sometimes with a
little bit of that like I was like a
young scallop or something and they were
just a hearty sailor and they just
wanted to bite in a daddy little daddy
at the time because I was
but anyhow what I'm saying is I remember
being a child and thinking man you know
wonder what the future is gonna be like
I wonder what the future is gonna be
like and now here we are here we are in
the future let me turn this audio up a
little bit so I can catch you guys man
there we go right there yeah now we are
in the future and I'm happy to be here
with you guys
it's 2018 happy New Year to you
2017 is over if you had something
flashing back there you know if you had
a little bit of grease lightning
electrocuting your insides then that's
over if you had something I bet you had
something good happen to everybody looks
at 2017 I see all these things so glad
it's over
dude 2017 that [ __ ] was wild you know
I've been alive for 37 of these things
of the spacial roundabouts you know I've
been alive for 37 of these outerspace
disco spins and I'll tell you this that
that this one was the wildest people are
feeling lit up people are feeling erect
in their souls I think fired up you know
people people don't people want this or
don't want that people are you know
standing up for this and stick you know
uncertain about that last year made me
think last year made me think about who
I was made me think about who I was man
you had a lot of stuff last year you had
the election going on and made you think
like well you know what what's your line
in the sand for for you know what
America is and what America isn't and
and and what you want the future in this
country to look like and who represents
that you know even if you don't think I
mean and I'm not a fan of politicians I
think the past I'd probably say maybe
thirty years in politics have been a
sold out in America where it's you know
it's just big businesses these these
politicians are just puppets
but but you know it's like we had this
past year with you at least you had to
kind of pick a side in your heart a
little bit
are you had to see you know when you can
see through the cracks now of these
people you know you can see how you know
how grimy and gritty these people get to
get this office and how much of an
egomaniac you have to be to live I bet
in that whole political world but it
made you stand up last year and think
you know you had the black lives matter
that that you know that was abundant
last year made you think man some people
were like yeah well [ __ ] it you know
this and some other people were like
well you know what are you kneeling for
you're at your job do your job you know
I don't call you know I don't you know
stop by Starbucks to ask the barista how
they feel about something
I stopped by Starbucks to get coffee you
know so I stopped by the NFL to get
football you know that it's an escape
from you know the the the the callings
and the questions of society but but
neck last year was it was inflicted you
know one where everything was on top of
the other thing there was no walls there
was no separation
everything was flooding into everything
else and I you know what I it was tough
I mean there were some weeks there where
I just couldn't for again stand just the
media just but how the media just just
has so much blood on their hands but
takes no accountability there were times
I couldn't stand how the lack of empathy
you know there were times where I
couldn't stand it but no but it also it
just made me question maybe question
well do I do I have racism in me do I
have do I you know you had the the woman
gate at the end of the year and I'm
gonna call it woman gate but you had you
know this and all year you had this you
know this fire this fire by a lot of
feminists and
look feminism I support a hard-working
woman getting what she wants in the
world I support a woman not having to
feel like they like that they don't
matter and not having to feel like they
don't have any value I support anybody I
want anybody feel that way but then
there's also a band of straight up man
haters out there who don't want anything
good for men who want to be evil you
know and who don't even want to
acknowledge the beauties of women some
of the natural beauties of women being
able to make children and be able to you
know have the ability to mother you know
it's just women that just want to make
money and I don't dude if you asked me
honestly as a soul not as a man but if
you could make money or if you could be
a mother create something with your body
dude I'd be a dang mother all right I'd
be a mother with a mustache so you know
what I'm saying I still keep my manhood
but but it made me question you know
that whole you know and it's it's it's
still going on am I saying it stop but
there was a lot of like stoking of the
fires asking us last year who we were
who we are and it's man it made me think
do I look do I look at when do I treat
women a certain way have I always you
know if I do where does it come from is
it because of a relationship I have in
my mouth in my past and my family when a
woman talks am i listening to her
differently am i looking at her
differently made me ask myself these
things you know it made me ask myself
about race what you know racism about
where someone do I have do I have views
you know if I'm walking past I mean I'm
the town I grew up in it was black and
white so my history with a lot of race
and a lot of the racial issues in
America are black and white so I would
think do I do I listen if I'm talking to
a black man if I'm talking to if I'm
meeting a new black friend do I have
certain views or certain call it do I
feel different than if I'm meeting a
white person
maybe ask myself some questions and I
like that some people don't want to feel
some of that discomfort of asking
themselves questions and that's fine
that's fine if you don't want to but I
don't think you have anything to lose by
doing it and I think even though 2017
was wild and it was fiery you know in
Trump one office you know but look I'll
say this dude that was the most sad or
that was 2016 91 or whatever but he got
inaugurated that was one of the most
savage things ever you know I mean that
was gangsta that that dude snuck in mr
steal yo office cuz there was a there
was surely a moment when everyone was
riding down the street after Trump got
elected thinking to themselves man [ __ ]
I could be President I could be
president like okay you want to talk
about giving everybody hope man a gay I
mean look the guy is certainly an
egomaniac he's an empath you know he
probably never was loved in his life it
seems like if you look into the history
about him and his father you know he
probably doesn't know about love he
probably doesn't you know he's probably
he's probably he just has a lot of it
you know is not very empathetic at all
but but he's a you know he's a dirty
business man that's what he is but also
that's what most of this [ __ ] country
is these days you know that's what most
of politics is these days is dirty
businessmen so am I surprised that he
ended up there I'm not at all I am not
at all you know and I think he captured
some of that that the I don't want to
say the poor white vote but just do
white people have been looked down upon
so much when you're poor and white dude
the only thing you have a lot of times
is you know your belief in America and
your and religion and Hollywood beats
those things up you know so I think
Hollywood can't even ruined a lot of
that vote you know by just saying you
know you know just being very anti kind
of the
white and blue idea of America even if
that's an advertised old-fashioned idea
I think Hollywood beat that idea up you
know in Hollywood's always you know it's
just I mean so many shows I feel like
beat down on religion a lot and when
you're poor man trust me look dude I've
been right there you know there were
many years in my life where the only
thing I felt like I had somewhere inside
of me was the the hope that a higher
power or a God out there cared about me
or loved me
so when you beat up on that kind of
stuff man you're gonna have people rebel
you're gonna have people angry and and
it's rocky man it's rocky but 2017 made
me personally think a lot made me think
about things and here we are man we're
in 2018 and I'm not gonna you know I'm
not dwelling but but we got a lot of
cool stuff happening here on this past
weekend I'm gonna get into a couple of
things that happened to me actually this
past weekend I got to perform for both
of the Rose Bowl teams Georgia Bulldogs
and Oklahoma Sooners
that was straight crispy that was crispy
Yamaguchi I'm gonna talk about that
I'm gonna talk about my New Year's Eve
plans I went back home and visited my
family if you haven't checked that out
on YouTube you can meet my family
it's called meet my family Christmas on
YouTube on my youtube channel make sure
to subscribe please I appreciate your
support I'm going to announce a couple
of stand-up comedy dates January 11th
through the 14th I'll be at the Brea
Improv in Brea California January 18th
through the 20th I'm at the new comedy
club in Jacksonville Florida February
2nd through 3rd I'll be at the Oxnard
California at levity live February 22nd
through the 24th I'll be in Indio
California at fantasy Springs casino and
April 6th and 7th I'll be in Tampa
Florida at Rock Brothers brewing some of
those links will be available on theof
on Comm slash tour t oh you are
and some of those will be going up here
in the next week as we get those shows
put up but those are all real dates and
those are places that I'll be coming to
and if you want to go somewhere won't
you go to grey block pizza gray block
pizza man you know they that charter
sponsor of this past weekend they got
them calzones them salads they're the
only place in America that have that
salad pizza they got them gourmet pizzas
and then beverages get your thirsty get
you hungry get you great block pizza
18:11 Pico Boulevard Los Angeles on the
way to the beach stopping there crack
open your jaw open your mouth get that
man I'll tell you this these football
players if I had to pick one team I
don't even know when these guys play
actually they play Monday night based on
how they behaved as a group at the
comedy shows because they each each each
team there was a lineup we perform
different nights for each team one night
for the Georgia Bulldogs and one night
for them Oklahoma Sooners then boys out
of Oklahoma and I would say based on the
the the the ability to just the frenetic
Ness I would say that Georgia Bulldogs
was wild and boys was wild man we came
in it was just having damn they were all
dancing on the stage that was a crazy
thing so this team gets to the club
before and they're all eating you know
eating it they at the Hollywood improv
there and they got their team buses
outside and I put some of it up on my
patreon actually but they had the team
buses outside and I go inside and I'm
excited you know I mean I would tell us
you you know what the University of
Arizona I went to semester at sea I went
to Santa Monica College College of
Charleston I went to some different
spots you know but so you know
especially with that LSU vibe you you
know you're involved in that SEC
football and at the SEC supplies at
least I would say half the NFL and now I
know that's a lie but still the
good saying it and them boys them
Georgia boys man they were I mean they
were sitting up on top of the furniture
they're being wild a lot of them gold it
up Gold's it up in that grill you know I
mean just something one dude so gold it
up I wouldn't be surprised if he open
his mouth and a couple of old bearded
men came walking out with pickaxes I
mean that boy was just dang he was you
know he was filled up in the gills with
them magical with them magical nuggets
with the magical golden nuggets and we
also we got in there and perform it and
I'll tell you this I got up I was the
first guy up and I am white and man
I started out strong us I started out
hitting him boy I was hitting him I was
hitting him and all the white players
was probably I would say 75 25 75
percent black players 25% white players
and your life and some people are like
well what does that have to do with
anything Theo well it doesn't I'll just
say this the black players lot more
rowdy you black people are are more
rowdy man it's I'm not saying there's
nothing wrong with that
I mean black people supply most of the
world's entertainment you know I mean
it's what these boys were out there wild
and the white boys more docile more
docile in there so you had I mean then
Georgia the Georgia was setting I mean
just you know there's Cheney people
jumping around in the back and like some
dudes on their phone the whole time
didn't even care the worst part was
you'd be performing and some guy would
say something because these guys are 18
to 23 huge guys so there's a little bit
that machismo I mean I was intimidated
I'm just like oh man like I mean dudes
sitting right in the front looking at me
like they don't give a [ __ ] cuz also you
know I'm 15 years I'm 13 years older
than these guys so you know they're
light they're probably like what's this
you know this man
talking about and I'm worried a lot of
times that my materials gonna disconnect
some I mean I got up there and put some
hits on them but there was a couple
moments where I was like dang man this
is I feel sweat I was like man I was
sweating and I told him I was like man I
can't even imagine playing against some
of you guys I cannot even imagine but
they were more ch they were more wild
and the Oklahoma crew was more docile
and the Heisman Trophy winner Baker
Mayfield he wasn't there and it was me
Jeff Ross Chris D'Elia Donnell Rawlings
and uh and it was wild man it was
something else
it was something else on a percent man
the Oklahoma boys were more docile you
know just more chill a little bit more
maybe say respectful you know but I
think that's a little bit more like
Oklahoma there that the values there a
little bit more you know you kind of
expect a little bit more
I don't know respect but it seemed like
more organization but now we walked when
I first walked in and the O and the
Oklahoma players were on stage I mean
they just walked up on the stage at The
Improv at the comedy club and they're up
there they got two mics and they're just
roasting each other to psych just
literally just like like whenever they
you know do Rhymes and call each other
names and it was the worst it was
basically as people saying [ __ ] and
[ __ ] [ __ ] over and over again right it
was just like anything that would rhyme
with that it was funny to see him though
it was just like it looks like just like
in a movie you know but I mean the teens
were having a good time I will say that
it seemed like both teens were having a
great time some of these guys had never
been to a comedy show before so I felt
honored you know to be a part of that
experience for them like some of these
guys are sitting there like wow this
this occurs this happens stand-up comedy
I remember the first comedy show I ever
went to I was in Baton Rouge Louisiana
and they had a friend of mine won
tickets to the comedy club because you
know a lot of comedy clubs they do that
you won tickets thing and they call you
up say you won tickets oh I got an even
inter a drawing or like
we don't give a [ __ ] you won tickets and
and so you know we got the tickets we
went and I sat there and a man got on
stage and started making me laugh and I
was like wow this is a job I mean it
just blew my mind that that was a real
thing you could do and I laughed at this
man I think his name was Mark Gross in
years later I would work with him in a
comedy club and this before I knew I
wanted to be a comedian I just knew I
did want to have a regular job but I got
up there and he was I mean he was
killing me in Baton Rouge Louisiana at
the funny bone comedy club and they had
these big plastic cups that said funny
bone on them and you could spend you
know ten dollars and get a drink and
keep the cup but I remember thinking wow
unbelievable and that's the only live
comedy show I ever saw before I decided
to to get into the line of work myself
it's the only live comedy show I ever
saw before I decided to get into that
line of work I don't if you guys checked
out I shared it on my on my youtube
channel I want to thank a gentleman
named Mike at happy claw productions in
Atlanta he sent me a cartoon that he
made just of a random excerpt from the
podcast and I mean you helped make my
holidays and I got to show that to my
family and friends and they just loved
it I mean they just damn you know and
it's hilarious dude I look like you no
actually he made me look a little more
handsome in the cartoon you can check
that out you can check that out on his
on his YouTube page I shared it on the
mind but go there and support support
him what else don't want to tell you
guys I went back home went back home to
Louisiana I went to Mississippi I was
only able to do a short episode had a
nice time you know got to see my little
nieces and nephews and my nephew's just
getting along
you ever see a kitty you don't see him
for a while
you're like damn that kid is just long
and isn't it what do you remember
remember how weird it was when your and
the crazy thing is you don't anything
about this like he doesn't realize he's
growing I mean he realizes you know cuz
you know the parents will put the marker
on the door or whatever but to him it's
just he's just living his life but to us
it's like you know when you see him once
in a while your nephews or family
members and they're growing if they're
children then you're like wow that blows
me out you know surprising to see him
stretch out but it made me remember
being like remember when you come back
from school from summer break and like
the like the you were 11 or 12 years old
and suddenly one of your friends look
like a [ __ ] alien bruh remember that
you come and dude have like though all
of a sudden like one of his arms longer
than the like he hit like a growth spurt
you know I mean just like I mean just
like Bear Bryant was just living in his
in his DNA and just directing all kinds
of traffic in there like we're gonna get
him on the run and we're gonna keep him
on the run I'm gonna go go go and you
know you could just see like you know
isn't his chin was real like his body or
looks like what uh [ __ ] Daniel adjust is
she is your daddy uh a lien all of a
sudden he's got pointy elbows or he's
got a lot you know it was just so crazy
I remember when you saw that friend that
had that growth spurt or they had that
one friend that got the beard remember
that there was always that one friend
who hit that [ __ ] hair spurt and he
showed up all just you know just uh you
know just Hermit it out with that beard
eighth grade dude's got a clean as beard
and he would what bro he was soon
whoever the beard dude was the second he
got the beard he had it through the rest
of high school cuz he was the guy that
was gonna buy liquor for you he was the
guy that was gonna try and sign you out
of school or sign few of his dating a
girl at the middle school or junior high
he would go over there in try to
out of school you know he would pretend
he'd come to you know you try to send
him in uh if he didn't go to your school
you'd have him try to come to
parent-teacher conferences if you if you
got in trouble you know I remember we
had this dude at my school named rap
city right he was a little bit he was a
mixed he was mixed you know black and
white and and he had that but he had
white beard hair he had white person
beard hair and so raps II would but he
looked old do raps he looked like about
usually a mixed guy will look very young
you know mix dudes are the cat I mean
everybody wants to be mixed mixed dudes
didn't seem like they never have a
problem
you never see a stressed out mix dude
cuz they got it all they're living in
the Lambs nutsack they got it all and
this you know and so rhapsody sometimes
you would have him coming a
parent-teacher conference for you cuz he
went to a school that was all over in
Slidell Slidell Louisiana so and he
looked older so if you if you needed up
somebody to come and meet with your with
your teacher you'd hit up Rap City you
know if I I think at the time you know
25 bucks heated up that he'd hit up
those uh those PTC's for you and try to
be you know he was everybody step daddy
that was a good time and I enjoy being
young and that was fun but yeah those
growth spurts maybe he'd hit those
spurts and you would just you know that
was just so crazy to me how much people
children would grow and how much he'd
have that weird summer he showed up and
you know your buddy's eyeballs were
bigger you know he was just hitting a
growth spurt or you be at lunch you know
you in the morning he'd be dressed
regular and by lunchtime his shirt
wouldn't even fit him you're like damn
freaking Sheldon hitting that spurt boy
this dude sprouted two inches you know
over brunch he spurting out and those
were that was always fun but it's crazy
to think that you know suddenly you just
hit hit a point you don't grow anymore
but it was nice to see my you know my
nephew had grown some and it was just
interesting to see that
and see him evolve a little bit as a
person and have a little bit you know
when kids are three four five you know
they're just [ __ ] they are freelance
assassins their assailants they're
murderers without weapons dude if I keep
up if if if a man came in your house and
did what a three or four year old does
throw pain everywhere [ __ ] somewhere
that man would be in jail you know if he
had a weapon I mean you know like one of
my little nephews almost beat my
sister's eye out with a with a little
pet with a with a kitty litter scooper
and if he would have been you know if
you had that same genomes in a you know
old or if you have that three year old
mentality in a 30 year old they'd be a
killer but so it's just wild to see how
little children behaved but how they
start to mature it was interesting to
watch man is really interesting at a
good time on my family if you get a
chance check it out on YouTube you can
meet them and we had fun man my my my
sister makes me laugh and I got a sister
looks just like me but she's a girl and
and she always makes me laugh man but we
had a good time I have beautiful nieces
and nephews and you know I got to spend
time with my mother and you know not a
bunch of time and I didn't get her those
goats I didn't get my mother the goats I
was gonna get her you know two two goats
because if you get somebody one goat
you're a piece of [ __ ] because a goat
can be lonely that's goats number one
skill is to be lonely she always have to
give somebody two goats but I gave my
mother to go I didn't give her two goats
I was going to and then I decided
against it because she didn't want it
and in the end it was just what I wanted
but honestly I almost felt like I should
have trusted my instincts because I kept
feeling I saw on Christmas I saw her on
Christmas and then I didn't see her
after that because I had other families
that I had grown
living with and that I had to go to stop
by and see and a man I could tell a
little bit I think that she wanted me to
stop by and drop and see her I think she
just wanted me to see her and something
at that point she'd wished that I had
gotten the goats so so that I would have
had an excuse or another reason to come
by my mother has to take care of my
stepfather you know he gots Alzheimer's
or dementia you know he's out there on
them you know he's missing a few stacks
you know he's missing a few stacks and
his brain racks and huh so he always
mostly talk about the war and you know
he ready to shoot him up and everything
and he likes to put on his gloves and
take him off and my mother's his
caretaker so she has to spend a lot of
her time doing that but I guess I don't
know I missed uh I wish I'd have spent
more time with her I probably should
have you know I just had a lot I had a
lot to do I had a lot to do you know but
uh I don't know sometimes when I think
about my life it seems like my mother's
always been a little she's almost had
too much stuff to do her whole life to
be able to really spend time with me
there's always something that's pressing
that prevents me and her from spending
time together
you know and I guess that's you know
just a reason that there's a reason for
that I don't know what it is but maybe
you know more shall be revealed in the
future but good to see the family loved
him I hope you had a happy holidays and
and I'm happy to be back man I got to
tell you guys we had some calls that
came in for Matt Matt was on the last
episode and we got all so man I'm gonna
play this for you right now we're gonna
talk to this gentleman either on
Wednesdays episode or next month on
Thursday or next Monday's episode we're
going to talk to this guy he called in
and hit the hotline some of you guys
know one of my lines from my Netflix
special no offense is I wish people quit
shooting up movie theaters and start
shooting up [ __ ] Denny's Denny's
restaurant right well here we got this
call on the hotline here we go hey Theo
a wife and I were watching your special
on that with
last week and we both almost had heart
attacks what he started talking about
shooting up a daze because when I was 19
I'm went to jail for shooting up at
Denny's
the story I'd love to tell you there you
go you heard that general went to jail
for shooting up
Danny's and and hopefully we're gonna
talk to him I've already confirmed it
we're gonna speak with him he'll be our
first live call I don't know if that'll
be on Wednesday or on Sunday on
Thursday's episode or on Sundays but
we're figuring that out but I want to
thank everybody for your support because
you know it's helping me have an
assistant now Shai Chris beautiful
Latino gentleman and he's helping and in
Budd Galloway coming in and that dude
really has some issues he bud has some
real issues but but you guys have
support on patreon and support here by
viewing is is really helping man in gray
block pizza and everybody's support and
they it's just been it's been awesome
man so I'm super grateful yeah what else
dude let's get into some things huh let
me think about what else happened to me
this past weekend I'm going to dinner
tonight I got some comedy shows with
David Spade tonight for New Year's Eve
at the Comedy Store what else I think I
got four four sets tonight four or five
sets so I'm happy to put that down get
it done
I got a bad haircut so I am pissed I'm
[ __ ] pissed bro dude this lady surfer
I went to [ __ ] Floyd's dude I went to
Floyd's and I didn't go to my usual guy
because it was one of those things where
I wanted my haircut right then you ever
get that thing like your dude your lady
or you dude you go to to get it cut to
get that that chip out to get that ship
shape they're not available so I wanted
to get primed up you know I just want I
was just feeling you know probably
feeling less than or feeling defeated or
something I don't know a little bit of
some [ __ ] and I was like I need to get
haircut now go to Floyd's everybody's
booked up the man said be a half-hour
I'll wait it's an hour and 10 minutes
later and I should've and this lady said
she'll take me this
lady she looked like a this lady look
like a [ __ ] clown that couldn't get
work
she had like her hair was all dyed green
in the middle like around the she had a
butt cut and then it was dyed green
right I know my hair looks like [ __ ]
brah
but she was she just had the worst
[ __ ] haircut she had the worst
haircut she had on the thickest glasses
ever I'm like there's no way I wouldn't
let this lady cut a yard I wouldn't let
her cut a hundred acres of grass that
didn't have a width I would because I
wouldn't be afraid she'd hit a tree even
if there was no trees out in that grass
this broad would bring a tree in from
somewhere and run that [ __ ] over with a
push mower just because she just had
that in her and man one and I still and
I still let her cut my hair
and do she thinned it out I mean I feel
like a damn test animal she clipped off
some of that some of the the falls in
the back and just made me furious you
know she just I mean I've just been so
furious at this green mollusk that cut
my hair this far-sighted green mollusk
then I'll let take a pair of scissors
upside my head and why I continue to
make that choice year after year
letting some [ __ ] [ __ ] dung
Muppet criminal do that to me I mean you
just shouldn't be allowed to do [ __ ]
that you can't do there's no way this
lady can cut hair there's no [ __ ] way
dude I oh man I wouldn't let this
[ __ ] lady cut a piece of paper with a
sword dude I just I'm just so I'm just
angry I've been dealing with some of
that anger I've been dealing with some
of that anger
we got some good calls in and coming in
first let me - we're gonna get to some
news let's get to a little bit of news
man let's do that
I'll tell you this right here the piss
at this store is Cobra a 34 year old
Washington man was caught giving a
massage to a 14 year old boy then
slipping him that ten dollar bill and a
thank you note the police were able to
track down the man who was later found
out to be the notorious piggyback bandit
whose claim to fame was tricking male
high school athletes into giving him
back rides in an attempt to reform
himself he decided to give in instead to
hand out massages at the airport to
teenage boys and thence and then slip
them a note with a $10 bill in it first
of all the fact that he was the
piggyback ride bandit I'm actually gonna
look this up even more because the story
was ridiculous the piggyback ride bandit
he was working at this was him Montana
something why it said that the stocky
man showed up in a basketball uniform
for a game at century high school in
North Dakota players and coaches assumed
he was a fan who had come with another
team so nobody objected when he began to
pitch in around the bench that is like
that's a freakin next-level pedophile
and I don't even know if this guy was I
mean look there's one thing massaging an
athlete you know somebody these boys is
strong and you want to get up there and
touch a tricep you know or you want to
feel a ring you know you want to [ __ ]
feel around a [ __ ] young fellas femur
you know I think there's a difference
there's a difference if you doing it and
you you know you skeet now if you're
going and hiding in a van afterwards or
you know putting your back against a
tree in the dirt in the woods you know
in flow you know and bliss flossing
sauce onto the earth that's different
but if you were just you know you want
to touch a young buck and remember what
it was like to be young I mean that's
just a little bit of a vibe I think he
makes himself appear as if he's limited
or handicapped
limited we're all limited man say what
you mean is he wearing a [ __ ] neck
brace is he wearing a [ __ ] dick
holster you know does he have his legs
tied together what's he [ __ ] doing I
hate it when reporters are so vague we
didn't realize what we're dealing with
until several days later the piggyback
bandit Sherwin che Egan of both El
Washington okay from Washington 28 year
old man who integrates himself with high
school sports teams then hoists his five
foot a 240 pound frame onto the backs of
the student-athletes so I guess he gets
them he gets in with the teams it seems
like then he asked the players for
piggyback rides
man I got to say respect to this dude
this is the Rudy Ruettiger of pedophiles
right here you know he's out there just
looking for some he's probably really
looking for male companionship like in a
way where you know what brotherly you
know and it probably is if he's got a
little bit of that Tisza more if he's
got it you know you know if he's wearing
that you know if he's one of God's
favorites then he might be you know he
might be expressing it in weird ways
he's pretended to interview athletes for
a term paper acted as a team acted as a
team manager or just tried to blend in
with the crowd for a piggyback payoff
he's been nicknamed the piggyback bandit
he's a lengthy criminal rap sheet in
Washington dang and that's Washington
you got to probably do some wild [ __ ] up
in Washington get a rap sheet because
it's mostly the woods you know mostly a
lot of [ __ ] you could chalk up to mother
nature you know if you out there you
know if you out there giving fellatio to
a lamb you could probably say look I'm
just trying to stay organic you know you
know from farm to Tong that's what the
that's what this meal is from farming a
tongue somebody said this an executive
director at the Montana high school
Sports Association what's disturbing to
me is that he is jumping on our young
athletes he is 240
pounds and he can hurt someone yeah well
not if your athletes got some balls in
their sacks Marc Marc out here with this
[ __ ] put your boys in a gym Marc let
me tell you this smart if your
student-athletes
can't carry around a handicapped fella
on their back then they're probably not
gonna make it in athletics don't you
just call them students then instead of
student-athletes in October Shai Egan
was arrested in Hellena Montana for
jumping on to unsuspecting high school
soccer players during a state tournament
boy whoo boy that's that uh when you try
to do that two-person crowd surfing
that's that two-person crowd surfing
that's all Shay goons doing man that's a
wild surprise when somebody doesn't know
you about to crowd surf and then you
just jump on top of it 240 whoo that's
America boy what else they have here he
pled guilty on February 1st to two
misdemeanor assault charges the jaw the
jaw and other sizes got me laugh as hard
the judge told him go back to Seattle
and behave that's what the judge told
him judge Bob would I like that man
another another game he showed up at
they said I think at one point he was
giving water to individuals well
he's helping out you know who else does
that mother nature mother nature gives
water to individuals and if she jumps on
her on your back or she tried to touch
your thigh a little bit or squeeze
around that soft skin or I'm you know
around behind your knee in a little fold
of your leg right there you're gonna
call the cops on her no you're not gonna
so won't you think about things you know
before you guys just reporting this dude
who probably has afflicted you no come
on man give this guy a break oh sorry I
just caught one more quote in this story
it said he was jumping on players backs
after they showered and came out of a
locker room
now that's pretty gangsta that's pretty
gangster man cuz it's hard to jump on a
wet person's back it's hard to you know
because if somebody wet you could slip
off them and it's hard to land and hold
on to a wet person you know we used to
play a game like that you know when we
would grease each other up sometimes you
know and this is right before it got
real hot you know around the last cold
front of the year we would put all
I'll get that can of Crisco they used to
have before everybody started to have an
olive oil they had this thing called
Crisco is a can of white like hard sauce
and your mother would have it at your
grandparents would have it and they
could do anything with it I mean they
could fix the car they could uh you know
they could spackle in a wall hole you
could do anything with this [ __ ] you
could fill a cavity you could start a
cavity you could fix your hair I mean my
buddies my buddies uncle used to gel
down his neck hair he had so much neck
hair he would gel it down there straight
down into his chest hair and he's do
that sometime with Crisco but we're kids
we would put Crisco all over our bodies
and we'd get out there in the yard and
tackle each other and play football and
that was always the funnest time that
game when people would do that but uh
but man that's a wild story and that's
the piggyback ride bandit strikes again
that's what that story was and uh and
we'll share this we'll share this clip
out on the YouTube this clip alone Apple
admitted they're slowing down the
iPhones you heard that but a bunch of
[ __ ] these company man it's just [ __ ]
that they're already making so much
money and they're gonna [ __ ] people like
that I hope if North Korea shoots
something it hits somebody like that it
hits one of these companies that's just
taking advantage of of mass of the
masses cuz I don't think it's right I
don't there's nothing more cuz that
ruins everything you know you're a
mother trying to keep in touch with your
kids you're trying to keep in touch with
a loved one you're trying to watch a
video your family's and it just slows
your whole life down a little bit you
know and when they I mean I eat and we
all know it we all know like suddenly
you're from everybody's phone
doesn't work the update screws it up man
I hope if they fire a missile boy land
one over there
whoever made that decision land it right
in a ass
put a little Crisco on that sucker and
if it doesn't blow up and it's just
lodged in there but send him my boy che
Egon that piggyback bandit and let him
get that hit her boy what else that's
all we got man in that we had a lot of
colons in it now our last full episode
we had a guy named Matt call in and I'm
gonna say fat Matt Matt was calling in
and saying had some eatin issues he also
said he doesn't like to drink water
plain plain water
it was his actual term which is just
water and I'm not calling him fat Matt
to make fun of him I'm just saying look
if your name is Matt and you're thicker
we've all been bullied somehow dude my
name is Theo right they called me pee Oh
Theo cuz I wet the bed right well you're
thinking no well you know yeah okay that
makes sense I went to bed alone was
thirty bruh thirty so you know we all
got something you know if you're Cindy
and you got a lot of body gas they call
you Wendy Cindy you know if you're mark
and you're an arsonist they call you
spark mark you know if your name is uh
if your name is [ __ ] you know if your
name is Tyson and you are a new date
asian chicks they call you Rice and
Tyson Rice and Tyson or if you use ricin
like they use in Breaking Bad to poison
people they call you ricin Tyson you
know I'm just saying they all have you
know we all got these shady little
everybody's got something so this fellow
was called Matt that's his name unless
it was an assumed name and Matt I thank
you for calling man I've never had the
issue of too much weight I've had the
issue of being skinny that sucks too you
know I mean I feel like you're just as
afraid to take your shirt off when
you're skinny at the pool you know you
look like you know
somebody that came out of an internment
camp or like a you know you look like
somebody that just got released from
some you know some prison where they
don't feed you so I can't you know I
can't relate a hundred percent but I can
relate and feeling inferior or feeling
different but we had some advice that
came in for you Matt and I want to I
want to put that into a segment right
here for you
and and so here we go Sophie oh I wanted
to call in and offer some advice for the
side dude yeah man he definitely sound
like a man this guy coming in hot right
there and Matt I'm not siding with this
guy who's called he calling you the Fed
you know my siding with that but uh but
look he's being he's being for less it
sounds like he's being poignant let's
hear what he's got to say you mentioned
you don't like plain water so that makes
me think you're drinking soda and you
know you can't be doing that man sugar
wheat and refined carbs are very bad for
us and I don't think we should be eating
him at all I think we should just be
eating those cooked meats and basically
protein and fats now well I want you two
to start waking up in the morning and
going for a walk on empty stomach Matt
well you got some points there and that
might be some of the hard truths right
there Matt you know if you're listening
to this but that is that's real you know
going for a walk on the empty stomach
eating cooked meats get out there boys
fill your mouth with the cut of that
dove try something fancy try a hard
salami you know try something wild you
know get it have some rabbit get it
[ __ ] cut a bark off the internet hit
you up with some aardvark they got sites
that sell it
eat that elk you know or get you a fine
turkey meat you know do say you know I'm
saying if you want to change you called
it about to change this guy's giving you
some hard truth here now so I'm gonna
let him ride it let's keep going
homeward you know put on put on CEOs
podcast and go for an hour-long walk in
the morning and what that's going to do
is that's just going to speed up your
insides basically that's gonna that's
going to make everything a little bit
faster in there throughout the day and
there you go that's a life hack right
there and thank you for calling with
that advice you know he's dropping it on
you you know I kind of wish that fella
could have said a little bit
or you know maybe have a little more
compassion in it you know like look Matt
understand I'm you know I have this
issue and here's maybe some suggestion
but he wanted to hit you straight he
wanted to give you that hit him man he
wanted a gray block you and that's what
happened you got that so that's some
advice right there he's saying get that
get your walk get your motor going
before you put gas in it so that way
when the gas goes in you already burning
you know you burned him before you start
churning and that's that let's hear a
little bit more Matt I want to give you
a couple more callers a that hit the
hotline and the hotline is nine eight
five six six four nine five zero three
and it's a hotline where if I can relate
to any young men out there or women but
you know this is a this isn't a man show
but this show has started off where we
offer basic life suggestions for adult
men and and that's if it's just if it's
if it's something I can relate to I'll
share my experience so you're not really
so you're not having to experience it
alone and if I can't
sometimes I'll present it out to the
audience and see if I if other men can
help you out or other women you know
this isn't uh this isn't just men but
you know this predominantly men onward
[Music]
Andrew from Minnesota Minnesota one of
the states where you're least likely to
get pink eye did you know that you do
now this is what works work for me when
I went on my last diet now I think it'd
be beneficial if you cut up eaten until
you really actually hungry now that's
something that I think a lot of people
overlook is they think they're hungry
but they're really just craving food you
really just want to eat something
man I feel that and I can relate to that
even because I'll notice if I get up in
the morning and I eat immediately
something big it so it's just a habit
you know I find that I get my most work
done and most effectively if I don't
even eat until lunchtime I mean I'm
scared
I mean look I'll be honest by then I've
had two or three coffees and I'm
skittish and I almost want to probably
cry or take a nap and call my mom but
I've gotten some stuff done let's hear
more and then guess what you're gonna be
so hungry that that salad that can of
tuna that chicken thigh that's got
nothing on it but a little salt and
pepper you know that's gonna start
looking really good man you're not gonna
be able to lie to me and tell me that
that's not gonna start looking good you
got to get really hungry man oh I like
that he's saying you got a David
Copperfield that gut so if your gut see
something of course if look if my gut
warrant wakes up and is lurking around
and see a hot cake see a little dish of
syrup then my gut is gonna jump on that
right but if my gut gets burning if I
take a 10 minute walk you know if I take
a you know a little stroll around or get
moving to my guts burning and then I'll
wait two hours then that hunger built up
that hunger back there flex him back
behind you boy that hunger is peaking
out you know it's peeking out from
behind your spine and you know dropping
out of your [ __ ] and peeking around
from under your nuts because that hunger
starts looking for something then you're
not living off a habit you're living off
of hunger and that's when you read a
Apple that's when you have a just a
small stack of cheese you know that's
when you'll have just a little you know
even just mix some salt and pepper in
your hand take that you know that's what
we used to have when I was young man and
they used to call that a coal miner
cigarette when you would just mix salt
and pepper in your hand and just have it
like that real fast and a lot of coal
miners used to do that because they
couldn't smoke down in the mines because
sometimes they had natural gas in there
so they'd have that coal miner cigarette
they take a little salt little pepper so
no you get a little bit of snuff put it
in there it's you know circle it around
in their hand take it to the pipe throw
that [ __ ] down your throat get spicy and
get salty and get [ __ ] get twisty off
that that's enough powder let's hear a
little more actually hungry you can't be
craving food you have to actually be
hungry a lot of people say they're
hungry they just craving food boom
that's true the boys on it he's on it
like a hornet that bull staying his
sister that will leave a baby in your
family you know what I'm saying that
gentleman right there you could tell he
gets in he's effective and he gets out
let's say that's that freakin that's
that freelance Tony Robbins right there
that gentleman was his name
hey that was Andrew that was wild Andrew
out there just firing boys a sniper
here's the facts jack one more call for
you Matt hey what's up - yo this is
Anthony oh just want to leave a quick
comment about Matt from Cleveland who's
having a tough time
eating healthy food and thanks for
calling Moore and prefers non-playing
water I think the thing that Matt needs
to do first is clipping a little [ __ ]
ass [ __ ]
and I don't mean that to be funny so I
don't know that's my advice
peace out hope it helps Matt damn and
that's gutter right there he just said
quit being a [ __ ] ass [ __ ] and
sometimes do tonight you know and I'll
say this so with the new assistant I'm
not hearing these calls before so this
is the first time that I'm hearing these
calls in their entirety if it's one that
I need to have some reference point on I
will but but so this is the first time
I'm hearing this I think that's you know
I think that that's the someone we have
to hear that someone you have to have
somebody tell you the [ __ ] truth
because we're out here living in this
sauce this and that but there's
effective ways to do it you know
sometimes there's more effective ways
than just calling somebody a [ __ ] you
know and [ __ ] you know cutting their
back open and putting [ __ ] you know
glitter in their in their wounds you
know but there's there's other those
ways to do it you know but sometimes we
just have to [ __ ] hear it alright
what else oh man I know everybody ahead
thank I want to thank everybody for
coming on the
banane easy tour last year and we got
this call that came in on the hotline
right here this fellow let's go see oh
my name's Austin I'm uh I'm from Oregon
up here just south of Portland so one
night I was working on the farm that I
live on it I'm working away and I heard
you on your other podcast allegedly
talking about hamster farms and yep I
grew up in a hamster breeding area and
that's true there Austin I grew up in
the stray animal belt let's hear more
and also I'm gonna be in Portland
actually I want to tell you guys that I
forgot I'm gonna be in Portland at
Harveys comedy club and that will be on
February 8th through the 11th at Harveys
in Portland Oregon not Maine in Oregon
Portland Oregon at Harveys all right
let's hear more the one night I was
working on the farm that I live on it
I'm working away and I heard you on your
other podcast allegedly talking about
hamster farms and I thought it was crazy
because I live on hamster ranch I was
right in the middle of feed the hamster
so I was kind of freaking out I just
it's in there by myself feeding hamsters
listening to you talk about hamsters
that's beautiful boy that's beautiful he
out there is everybody been thinking
over the time that I'm not coming at you
with the reality of things that I didn't
that I didn't grow up in a hamster
breeding area that I didn't that I
wasn't raised in the stray animal belt
get with me let's hear more I'm so I
started looking into it more what's the
deal with hamsters what's with Bo and
hamsters I thought it was pretty funny I
was feeding hamsters and randomly you
were talking about hamsters and and I
live on this hamster ranch at night I
don't know what I'd do without you
guys's podcasts and and every night when
I'm feeding baby hamsters I'm listening
to allegedly listen all the old back
episodes and new ones when they come out
and if you're ever in need of a hamster
ranch sponsor or if you're ever in the
Portland area next baby week ago she ate
something with the hamsters or just tore
or something one
percent Austin a hundred percent I'll be
hitting you up when I come into town
over that weekend and that's February
8th through the 11th Harvey's in
Portland Oregon
maybe we even get a couple of listeners
out to it as well you know maybe we'll
do something special I'll be in touch
with you I appreciate that
and you know that that man if you with
you if you if you if you can't think of
something to bring you joy people if you
can't think of something to bring you
joy no did that man out there feeding
them little hamsters he out there
feeding them little hamsters at
nighttime one man doing all of that work
and that is a small God that man is a
small God those little mouths and be
feeding him water he'd feeding him milk
he feeding him sugar water man that's
beautiful thank you for calling Austin
thank you for calling a lot of cool
stuff on this episode happy New Year to
you guys do have some resolutions yeah I
got some resolutions there just general
you know still battling with trying to
quit smoking I had 14 days of no smoking
and then I got something happened after
a comedy showing on us felt irritable
and discontent and then I smoked a
cigarette and then I've probably had two
cigarettes a day since then so you know
I'm flirting with with quittin but it's
just not there yet but I'm trying
outside of that I want to get back in
shape this year I want to try to get in
shape so I can relate to you big Matt I
can relate to other people I'm trying to
get in shape as well
and those are really my New Year's
resolutions there general and just
continue to try to you know learn a
little bit more about myself and then
just trying man I just and just I don't
know just let go of my will and let go
of my ego and to get better at comedy
those are my goals we had some callers
that came in would call them with a
couple of issues and we're gonna get
this one and if you guys have any
thoughts this seems like one I haven't
heard it yet but this is from Danielle
here we go hey Theo my name is Danielle
I am 25 and a virgin not by choice but
due to lack of takers throughout the
years mmm
well this sounds like Danielle is
reading this like she wrote it in
advance and that's okay let's back up a
little bit and keep playing it here we
go
not by choice but due to lack of takers
throughout the years
okay so Danielle is still a virgin due
to lack of takers are you trapped
somewhere Danielle let's hear more I
think it's a rarity in this day and age
to be 25 and a virgin and I worry it
will be a turn-off for any guy when he
finds out and that only heightens my
insecurities about it
so I would just love some insight into
this pickle of a situation from a male
sexual connoisseur such as yourself
well that's a while when you're 25
you're still a virgin because of many
male takers
it does seem wild in this area cuz they
got some fellows out there you know you
would think most fellows would I mean it
definitely makes you nervous I think as
a man because you got that first of all
you're that you you know you you sending
in that initial that initial thistle so
you're gonna be you know you feeding
that first dolphin this gonna be the
first time your little dolphin gets fed
when you catch a num when you catching a
little bit of D from somebody and does
it turn men off I mean I would just
wonder if you feel like you have to tell
them I guess you probably do because you
want you know they got to know if you're
working and you know in a novice
universe
sorry somebody just ring the doorbell
making sure everything's okay yeah like
you want everybody to know that you know
that you know that there's wet paint if
you will so that's something you
probably want them to know but is it
turning men off is it a turn-off I think
it's exciting to some men you know
there's something in that you know in a
man that wants to get that you know
there wants to get that squirrel in his
mouth you know sometimes you don't want
to buy the beef jerky some time you want
that raw meat and so a lot of men are
gonna be thinking like that whoo that's
a tough one that's a tough one
I don't know how would I feel if a girl
told me that if I didn't care about her
at all I would be like do I want to go
here do I want to have sex with this
girl just to get some cut up just to get
some hot wallet do I want to do that
because then I'm gonna be burden on my
conscience with that I did that just for
my own take and at 17 16 15 18 it's a
little different because I mean at that
at that age you're just running around
with an erection
you know you'll [ __ ] anything I mean you
will put your dick in anything you'd put
it into a sharp vagina even if somebody
told you you had a chance of not getting
cut I mean it's just that's it you know
it's different back then and you're not
thinking about the repercussions or if
anybody's feelings are involved around
25 you know if you're gonna date a man
at least your own age or lose your
virginity to a man of at least your own
age then that man probably he might be
questioning some things you know he
might be wondering you know he might be
worried about if he's gonna feel bad if
he's just trying to you know take your
uh your you know your virginity if
you're just trying to steal that steal
that squeal so that's a tough one
tonight you know what i'ma put that out
to our callers if you guys have any
thoughts or suggestions for Danielle
there
cinamon still a virgin at 25 let's hear
the end of it again so know exactly what
she's asking so I would just love some
insight into this pickle of a situation
from a man okay it's a little further
back in this day and age to be 25 and a
virgin and I worry it will be a turn-off
for any guy when he finds out and I mean
look I but then now is I'm thinking
about a little bit more it's starting to
turn me on a little so there you go with
a man at first maybe I'm a little bit
considerate about it but then after a
while that's the dog is getting out you
know at first I'll show you the
parakeets out front you'll see the
pretty birds but in the back they got
that dog and he's starting to stretch
and he's starting man you know so now
I'm thinking it'd be nice to get out in
there
get that hitter from you so I've looked
if you if you guys have any suggestions
for or ladies ninety five six six four
nine five zero three actually I think
that's more of a of a question for guys
is it a turn-off I mean it's exciting
it's adventurous it's your first time
people a man you know want to be a part
of that you know there's something
limbic and a man you want to be that
first ride you want to be that first
ferris wheel because also as a man if
we're no good then you don't know you
have no idea
you're gonna think no matter what that
were the best so I'll tell you this for
a dude that's that you know I'm that
professional bull rider out there you
know I'm eight seconds Ernie you know
I'm not that long I'm not that long song
you know I'm that prelude you know I'm
that I'm that fainting goat boy when it
comes to sex you know I'm that fainting
goat I'm not that sprinter I mean I am
that sprinter I'm not that long-distance
warlord so for a guy like me or more
guys like me yeah guys that know that
we're not that you know I'm not Thor I'm
Thurman you know I'm Thornton
you know I'm somebody nerdier than Thor
when it comes to that six you know to be
an out in that crotch so there you go
but guys if you got any suggestions or
thoughts for let her know
one more call right here let's take it
here we go thank you for calling Marissa
from Michigan essentially the lowdown is
that I'm kind of insecure given that I
know that he has a lot more sexual
experience than I do like I've never
felt insignificant or incompetent I've
always been pretty confident that oh I'm
good and bad like whatever this guy like
I know like the level of pay that he has
been able to drag in if you will I know
all these stories and stuff and we're
friends and it doesn't bother me hearing
them and I don't like you know part of
me is like yeah man you get it now that
we're kind of dating it makes me a
little bit worried
I wonder you know am I not I'm not up to
the standard am I not you know I'm
certainly not some Vegas porn star who
does it for a living I'm just a little
amateur off to the side here doing what
you can
but look you could be a freelance Froy
line and show up with some real skills
and I think this is an opportunity you
can surprise this dude because you're
saying he thinks he got all the magic
you know you know you're saying he
thinks he got the artillery and he got
the archery bows and he bring in wild
antics into the bedroom and he's gonna
you know do a backflip and land into
that posse I don't know this one you can
bring something wild in bring you a toy
or something hide something in his but
you know sneak something in fill his
mouth with cabbage and you know and
[ __ ] choke him while y'all having sex
you know tickle that [ __ ] you
know I'm saying surprise him with some
of your skills because those skills can
be anything put glitter in your mouth
and give him that [ __ ] he'll never
forget you because gonna take him a
month to get that glitter off his Wang
you know hide a little bit of [ __ ] put a
little bit of glitter in your pocket get
that pinched hide it in between his ass
twin between his ass saw cheeks you know
but party baby I'm feeling weak in the
cheeks but party you know you bring some
magic just cuz you ain't bouncing that
ass you know like a like a um just cause
you ain't bouncing that ass like a like
a Cadillac in a Snoop Dogg video doesn't
mean you can't show up and do something
crazy you know while he's [ __ ] you
turn around and [ __ ] kick him now
who's a badass in here now who's got
tricks see if he can [ __ ] when he can't
even catch his breath then we'll see if
he's a Conor McGregor or not Oh we'll
see if he's just a um you know a Larry
McGregor or a Dirk McGregor somebody you
don't know or never heard of so that's
what I'm saying bring your own tricks
into the bedroom doll and see what he's
got see what he's got I want to
thank you guys for coming out I want to
thank you guys for being a part of this
past weekend for the new year
we are going to have our first caller
call in we're gonna talk to we're gonna
talk to you boy who shot up that Denny's
right there a wife and I were watching
your special on that list last week and
we both almost had heart attacks when
you started talking about shooting up a
daze because when I was 19 I'm went to
jail for shooting up at Denny's well I
bet who had heart attacks was the people
who are pretty much almost if they did
caught them bullets from you so I'm
curious to hear more about that and
learn more about that we're gonna try to
have that on Thursday's episode
otherwise we'll do it next week I want
to thank you guys for being a part of
this past weekend thank you guys for the
support I'll see you in some of these
upcoming shows Brea California
Jacksonville Florida Oxnard La Jolla
Indio California Portland Oregon and in
Tampa Florida over in the next five
months more shows will be added soon you
can get a new this past weekend onward
shirt at theof on Comm slash store and I
want to thank you charter sponsor gray
block pizza thank you to all the callers
I want to thank you too shy Chris I want
to thank I want to thank the Lord above
or the Lord out in the earth or mother
nature I want to thank everybody that
got us into the new year and I hope that
this year's whatever you want I hope
this year is whatever you want but I'll
tell you this I bet I bet that you can
make this year what you want it to be
you know a friend of mine asked me one
time he said dude have you ever worked
really hard at something in your life
and had it not come to fruition and I
thought about it and the answer was no
no I haven't I've never worked really
hard at something and had it not come to
fruition so it just shows you man you
get out what you put in my New Year's
resolution is to try and be active
to take on the day to get out of my
brain get into my body and go onward
because you cannot think yourself in the
positive action but you can't act
yourself in a positive thing get moving
let's go onward welcome to 2018 thank
you guys for your love and support
[Music]